one of those gop leaders standing up to
biden is georgia governor brian kemp and
he joins me now
governor
the president says that you are being
cavalier with the lives of american
children
your reaction
well joe biden's talking tougher to
republican governors and unvaccinated
people than he did to the taliban which
is quite disappointing
you know i've been listening to the show
and i agree this is all about freedom
this is more government overreach
and where does it go next if it's not
this issue what is the next thing that
they're going to require businesses to
do we shouldn't have the government
deciding business decisions we should
let the businesses do that and you take
great companies in georgia many that
have you know tens of thousands of
employees
it's going to take them forever to even
if they do this to logistically put the
plan in place for vaccines or testing no
telling how much it's going to cost how
many people they're going to lose and
everybody needs workforce now they don't
need their people spending time being
the vaccine police they need them doing
their job and we're going to continue to
look for ways to partner with them to
fight back against this overreach
governor i have been worried since the
beginning of this pandemic that we would
come out of this pandemic looking more
like the chinese than like americans how
is this not like a chinese communist
style social credit system
well that's where it's going i mean
we're going to have the government
making every decision in everyday lives
including in our businesses and you know
i heard the president talking about the
concerns for children well our kids in
georgia have been in school for a month
now our cases are declining our
hospitalizations are starting to go down
we have fought through this letting the
schools deal with those issues at the
local level letting the superintendents
and the school boards keep our kids in
the classroom and now he's just now
coming out with this i mean if they were
going to do something like this i don't
agree with it but they should have been
doing this in june or early july not in
september right so tell me quickly
exactly what you think the governors
like yourself are going to do to fight
back because you're definitely in a
better position than say congress
well we're certainly the voice out there
right now to push back and i know the
governors i talked to today on a big
call are working with the state's
attorney's generals to see what the
legal
the legal plan would be on this we've
got to find out exactly how this is
going to work and how that case would
stand up but i think you're going to see
a lot of other business groups and
employers that stand up as well and
that's really who i'm standing with this
isn't about me versus the president this
is about me standing up for business
letting them make decisions versus the
government
congressman byron called for civil
disobedience do you agree
well listen i think everybody needs to
be civil in all of this and what the
president is doing is dividing the
country you know he's pitting the
vaccinated against the unvaccinated he's
already pitted the masked folks against
the unmask that's not what we need to be
doing we need to be educating people on
what the data says the science behind
the medical miracle of operation warp
speed and the trump administration with
the vaccine but also at the end of the
day
let people choose how they're going to
deal with their own health care that is
a personal decision as you well know
thank you governor appreciate you
joining me tonight